CBS News has fired the executive
producer of 60 minutes after he sent a
very pointed warning to a CBS news
correspondent covering misconduct
allegations against him CBS News says
Jeff Fager violated company policy but
would not specify how in a statement
figure blamed a text message he sent to
one of our own CBS reporters demanding
that she be fair in covering the story
now he has admitted that it contained
harsh language
Jericka Duncan is that reporter and she
joins us at the table this morning
Jericka very good to have you here thank
you so much and thank you for you all
support this morning our team has been
investigating published accounts of Jeff
Fager acting inappropriately and
tolerating this conduct so Sunday
evening I reached out to him for comment
on the most recent allegations he denied
them and then sent me a warning in a
text message Jeff Fager wrote if you
repeat these false accusations without
any of your own reporting to back them
up you will be held responsible for
harming me he went on to say be careful
there are people who lost their jobs
trying to harm me and if you pass on
these damaging claims without your own
reporting to back them up that will
become a serious problem this is the
board of stories Fager who led 60
minutes since 2004 indicated that
message is why he was fired in a
statement he wrote my language was harsh
and despite the fact that journalists
received harsh demands for fairness all
the time CBS did not like it one such
note should not result in termination
after 36 years before that language was
made public CBS News President David
Rhodes addressed the staff at 60 minutes
and what one employee calls an intense
meeting Rhodes faced questions from
journalists who were said to be
incredibly angry correspondent steve
Kroft later characterized fakers text
message to me as threatening and
inappropriate he added the situation
saddens me as he left the meeting Rhodes
wouldn't comment on whether the text
message was the reason he fired failure
however in an email to the news division
he wrote the dismissal is not directly
related to the allegations that surfaced
and press reports The New Yorker has
reported on claims
at Fager would touch employees in ways
that made them uncomfortable and allowed
harassment in the division Fager
has denied that as previous chairman of
CBS News Fager brought Charlie Rose back
to the network in the late 1990s Jeff
Fager my friend my colleague my boss CBS
fired rose last year over sexual
harassment allegations 60 minutes marked
its 50th year last season our job is to
seek out the truth and not everybody
wants the truth that Fager was only the
second executive producer in the show's
history the fundamentals haven't changed
over all these years and I and I really
think that's a big part of the success
the fundamentals of reporting including
asking questions of those we cover and
that's exactly what we were doing
Hagar Rose and former CEO Leslie Moonves
have now all been forced out of CBS
after allegations of misconduct to
outside law firms are conducting an
ongoing investigation into those reports
and into the overall culture here at CBS
never expected this no of course I mean
this is a very difficult story for us to
cover and certainly for you big trees
are falling at CBS but I really do
believe that the company wants to and
will get this right I can only imagine
what this what this has done to you how
this has affected you and I certainly
applaud you Jericka for speaking of what
was it like when you received that text
on Sunday I was shocked and like the
many people that I've covered you you
finally understand that conflicting
feeling about why and what and why would
you even put me in this position now I
spoke to someone here that I believe it
as a threat I did yes
and it's even hard to say that today
because yes we do receive harsh language
all the time but this is someone who
held an enormous amount of power here
who I respected and I was shocked I
think once people once people saw that
text they might have felt differently
about it it certainly sounded like a
threat it was a threat
yeah but I thank everyone here for their
support so many comments I can't say
that enough about the people within this
organization
sent me text messages emails viewers
people on Twitter so I'm extremely
grateful for them and we at CBS this
morning support you a hundred percent
thanks well as the news division thank
you to recap thank you